as guys my name is a chair now and
welcome to episode 6 of the game
programming series so last time we sent
our first little bit of data between our
Cline and our server it was pretty
exciting I mean I was on the edge of my
seat and and this time we're actually
going to move on to sending more serious
data and specifically our our actual
sterilization format right so our C
databases I believe that's what we call
them
I should really know this but yes I'll
see data base right so I'm gonna send
those over the network today that is our
goal so it's gonna be quite simple to do
that because we've got pretty much
everything we need to actually make that
happen if we take a look at our our
actual data base kind of format and one
like in terms of our API what it can do
then you will see that we have this
function here called get bytes right
which just gets us kind of the whole
buys I mean it writes all of our bytes
into this destination and you can see
that the destination is actually a byte
array right which is perfect because if
you look at how we're currently sending
stuff from our client we're literally
just typing in let's see where did we
actually send that our beam game I think
right what did we send from somewhere
else
client doc Kinect would have sent it I
think sent connection plug it yep so we
initially just do connection package gap
bytes and that's how we actually send
data so we've already written this send
data function so it's actually gonna be
really simple to transition that into
the thing that we want to send so
specifically what I'll do just to make
this kind of a bit easier and extend the
API is I'll quickly write a function
here that's called public void sand and
it'll be an overload that actually takes
in a database so we can just give it an
ASCII database and it will just extract
the box itself right just so that we
don't have to extract the byte array
ourselves that being said I do want to
quickly mention that if you have your
project set up correctly it should work
it should automatically recognize this
the database if it doesn't for whatever
reason you can always just make sure
that this rain project if you go to
properties and then the build path make
sure that rain cloud sterilization is
actually set under the required projects
on the build path if it's not you can
always hit add and then add the sir
ization project if you've got it
currently in here if you've exported it
as a jar or something then you can also
kind of set that off if you like by just
going into the build path and then
libraries and then adding an external
jar or jawless in the project and then
you can kind of link that in and it will
work basically the same way I wouldn't
recommend that though I'd recommend just
having the code here because that way if
we change everything or if we change we
change everything if we change anything
then we will like to just easily just be
able to I mean like we won't have to do
anything right listen if I change
something in here and then just run my
game again it's gonna use the updated
code and it's gonna be all fine whereas
if you're kind of running it as an
external library as an external traffic
light or something then you'll have to
rebuild that jar file would the changes
which is just gonna get really annoying
so instead of doing it manually just
link the project and you'll be fine and
so all this will really have to do
excuse me all this what all you have to
do is actually construct that buy it
array so basically if we just do
database top right in fact not that best
all right we need to create a first so
we'll do buy data rekkles new buy a
database dot get size that should give
us the size and bytes of how many of how
how large this database is and then we
can call database get bytes destination
of course will be data pointer will be 0
because we don't want it to we wanted to
start writing from the first byte in
this array and that's it right and then
of course we'll have to call send with
that data that we've just gotten so that
should be pretty straightforward and
that of course should send our RC
database now when it comes to the
receiving end of things and we'll of
course quickly write a test for this if
we go back to game and we connect the
client let's just say that's successful
whatever we'll deal with actually
setting this off next episode
I just want to set up all of our kind of
sending and receiving methods first what
we'll do is we'll create an ASCII
database DB was new or in fact I think
already
we're probably got one already don't we
yes what this thing so we save and then
I guess we load when we load the yeah
here it is set sighs okay so we've got
this thing here let's just just grab
that right there's just gonna be a bit
more exciting I think loading it from a
file first and then sending it to the
server so and then we'll do something
like clients and DB okay so you can see
that the way I'm kind of designing this
API is it is really really simple okay
all we want to do is like again we've
called this RC database which is
basically like a kind of a virtual
object kind of that contains everything
that we want and then all we really have
to do is just hit client ascend DB and
that's it it'll be shipped off to the
server we will probably end up you know
I mean if we have to we'll end up kind
of extending all this to make it a bit
more powerful and a bit more flexible
and probably work a little bit better
with like stuff like priorities and you
know various other things that we can do
to ensure the data is actually delivered
you know when required and stuff like
that but for the most part it is
actually going to be this simple so just
don't you know don't ever think this
whole multiplayer thing it's actually
really easy to make a basic kind of
multiplayer so that's what we'll do for
now to get the ball rolling down the
hill and then in the server side of
things this is where this is where all
of this stuff happens so we got this we
get this packet and then we just had to
process it the best way to quickly check
by the way you can see that what I'm
doing here is I'm saying that if this
string equals I'll say DB then bold blob
we can sterilize that's kind of exactly
what we really want to do is that I've
already written this code here I didn't
know we did that when I write this code
oh this was an example I think yeah
anyway
I didn't even know we had this so it
turns out we've already basically
written in the code that I want to try
this episode so instead we'll talk about
it I guess but you can see that the
header of our ization format is our CDP
right those bytes I know I keep
forgetting this I'm pretty sure that
this would be 8 bytes because Java I
think uses true byte chars but anyway
doesn't matter the point is I think that
I believe that this test should work if
it doesn't we can always just do it
another way but anyway a really good way
to check is basically by doing this
right so we check to see if I mean I
usually wouldn't even write it like this
I mean this is kind of risky what I
would do instead is actually define the
base myself so I'd be like you know
actually define numbers rather than
characters just because again that can
be a bit in this case of course this is
actually a string many I think it'll be
like utf-16 or something in this case
which will again mine
might not might not be what we want and
also means that header is a bi it's not
four so I might rewrite that in a minute
but I do want to see first what we
actually get on a server so assuming
that is correct we will of course
deserialize our database we'll done the
packet regardless this is not gonna work
properly for this I suspect because it's
going to just try and create a string
out of the data which is not going to
work out as then we're not going to get
the full dump because there'll be zeroes
throughout our database which will
terminate the string but we'll we'll
leave it in there anyway just for fun
can't hurt it means certainly not a
crash
I don't think and then so yes we've got
it's not a base and we will try and
process it so I mean I don't know for
now I'll just do something like receive
dollar base it's gonna be a really easy
kind of way to just check to make sure
that it's actually succeeded here yeah
that's the other thing like this I mean
the length is 4 in this case but really
like the length is probably gonna be not
force probably to be 8 I mean unless
that's the length of the string and not
the number of bytes yeah so I mean this
might just give us
see and not RC TVs it might be 8 bytes
let's let's check um I like how how
casual this is that's I guess running a
server we probably print something like
I started server on port I want to it
anyway and we'll run out game and so it
should send that database in fact here's
an easy way to check let's put a
breakpoint in client I'll send let's run
the game
I'll debug the game we'll switch to this
perspective whatever ok so it's also we
can note that the server has indeed
received what my dear I think the server
has indeed received that connection
packet cool because of course we sent it
up here now we're down here in the
client will send let's step into doubt
about here real quick
well are we in it so we'll step into
that let's see how big that is
83 bytes it looks like our 84 bytes will
retrieve the bytes from that let's check
what the bytes are ok that seems
reasonable so it looks like it is one
byte per child
apparently which is ok I mean that's not
what I expected but whatever all of that
and then of course we'll go to the
server side I guess we'll just step
through this because I want to see
exactly what happens
so in this listening we're in socket
receive let's just put a breakpoint
process over here and resume the client
ok there we go we we have hit the
breakpoint in the server and under
process so we'll try and step into that
and where are we this is a game so the
data that it receives from the packet is
for a while you can see does have our
header there
so if we step through this whatever we
have the port we have the address of
this which of course local host let's
see if this check works amazing you did
ok so it looks like it is one byte
char's huh interesting
I thought I thought they were to bite or
something I'm not sure maybe it maybe it
is variable maybe it depends on what you
actually specify either way I'm not like
this method I think is a bit dodgy but
anyway we do civilize the database which
luckily
and of course we can now see that on the
server side we now have this RC database
which didn't crash luckily and what that
has is one object
it's an RC object it's got three fields
3 RC fields anyway this is gonna be a
bit difficult to actually read because
of because it's just bytes so we'll
actually probably write a function now
to actually dump the RC database the
same way that we just dumped the raw
packet um in fact what was the role
packet I wonder anyway so we process
which of course says that we received a
database and that's it we're done
let's resume that let's stop both for
applications and take a look at this
server because I actually want to see
what happened there ok so you can see
the contents were a bit weird it didn't
actually didn't look like it did it
looks like it did actually print the
entire database which is a bit
surprising but you can see they don't
obviously printing as a string as a bit
weird and we get this but you can see
that it's called screen it contains
resolution the resolution I think it's
name of the object and then with height
and scale or the actual values ok so
roughly it is our database correctly
received let's actually write something
now to dump it because that'll be really
useful for debugging
we've got dump packet so I'll probably
make another private function here
called dump RC database
I actually might just like call it dump
and we'll do the same here because I
mean we might as well just use the power
of overloading to just have a thing the
same function name but with various
parameter types so ask the database
let's grab this I'm going to extend
these because they're clearly not long
enough you should do that here as well
just be neat
we are not dumping the packet in this
case so we're not going to worry about
the address or anything like that in
fact what we're really going to do is
just kind of go through and I mean we're
going to say that it's an ASCII database
we're also going to I think just
basically iterate through like every
object and every field and just kind of
print that stuff and every string it's
like that
so we'll say I don't use tabs here I'll
see database that's roughly in the
middle right I'm not gonna measure it I
really care that much and we'll have one
of these at the end as well okay so then
I guess things that are important right
the name so database table get name I
guess will print the size as well I
might just do like a little I might just
do like a little just prefix here that
kind of says name just so that we know
otherwise we'll just get right like a
random thing that says what the size is
just go like a random number and we're
like what's that this way we'll be like
ah that's the size because we we said it
was okay
so I guess object counts this is what
it's called right database dot objects
dot size
and then we'll iterate through them so
we'll say for RC objects objects in
citizen shop for us the object object
and in that's in database objects will
again print the name in size so we have
object or get name object or get size
whoops
and I guess we'll get the field count
for the objects we need to it like in
dentists as well I guess let's see how
we probably want to handle this
I imagine maybe we'll have like an extra
print line or something and then I guess
we'll say do you just want to say object
do we want to say object I guess I will
say tab and then object this is some
exciting code I'm writing right now by
the way I know you guys are just on the
edge of your seats
yeah debug code isn't particularly
exciting but it's also not boring like I
really like running debug code it's it's
nice I like I like writing like code
that helps me develop because it kind of
I mean on one hand you could argue it's
avoiding the problem of actually making
the thing work by just continuously
running debug code but also it does make
it a lot easier to kind of add things
and and definitely a lot easier to debug
if things go wrong and of course things
will inevitably go wrong especially
because we're so early in development
here but we basically have our object
I'll have a blank line at the end of
this so we have and then we have a field
count is what I meant obviously and
they'll be object dot fields to size and
then we have a for RC field field in
object or fields
we have a two tabs here oops
Oldfield and pull this I guess I guess
we'll have the name of the slides again
replace this with field
okay so this is where it gets a bit
interesting because what we're
realistically going to have to do is and
I'm just looking at code that I've
written earlier for this which you can
get by the way on the github branch
called multiplayer if you are a patreon
patreon of course com4 slash the Cherno
is Aleichem we can become a patron
anyway so that guy's already written but
I'm just looking at this and I'm seeing
if there's a better way to do this
probably not but basically we're just
going to remember it gives us our kind
of raw data and then what I ended up
kind of doing and I don't know why I
ended up doing this is a bit weird oh
because I wanted to print the roll tada
huh that's interesting we did probably
don't need to do that now I don't care
that much but yeah basically what we're
gonna have to do is have a little switch
on the field type and then of course
based on the type of that field since we
don't know and this is like a dump
function really just like just dumps the
daughter anyway we're gonna say case
type dot bite for example and then
that's just going to be we'll make a
string here called daughter or something
and then we'll just do data plus equals
field dot get vice okay so it's still
kind of like this data is a string so
it's still kind of just appending into a
string which will of course convert it
to a string but will basically have to
do that for all the types so the types
that we've got here are byte short chai
integer long float byte short sharp
integer
long flirt short get cha get integer
okay long I think it's just get in sighs
yep get flirts get double and get
bullying I guess all the types we have
double get bullying cool all right and
then we can print that pose so da da
plus da da I think that's two tabs we
have that and then we'll just have a
blank line all right so that is how we
print fields inside objects the other
things that we need to care about I
believe so I just like strings and stuff
so we can print like strings and stuff I
don't even know if we do we send strings
let's see like is in do we we just got
like three and so I might not bother
with that now but if we were to run this
hopefully we'll get something looks
decent after all this work but you can
see I've just written something that's
just gonna really easily kind of just
make sure that first of all we've got
the complete packet on the server we can
see what it actually is and just in the
future of course we'll make development
a lot easier and of course in the
meantime also proofs that we are
receiving the database correctly so
we'll just do something like you shall
receive database and then we'll dump the
database all right so let's start the
server green server debug as and then we
will also start the clients which is our
game oh we got a it's fine that's a
breakpoint exception okay cool and we
can stop both of them now
so on the server side we have received a
database and then here is the database
so we have the name is screen the size
is 84 bytes
it's got one object obvious that we have
the name is resolution sizes 63 bytes
account we have three fields with height
and a scale and their values at 2:21 six
eight and three which are reasonable
values their correct values okay so
there you go
I mean we've successfully managed to
transmit a data base from the client to
the server and you can see that what we
get is indeed correct so that's perfect
so that's gonna wrap up this episode
we're gonna have a bit of a shorter one
line this time I had a huge one last
time and I'm really trying to keep these
keep these as short as possible but
thanks for watching guys if you enjoyed
this video please hit the like button
next time we're going to actually move
on to we're going to move on to you know
sending that connection packet in
technology like basically building a
correct connection and making sure the
client is connected to the server and
then from then on I believe we'll
probably just move on to actually
managing clients so the server has this
job of having to manage clients right
meaning that like it has to actually you
know make sure clients are still there
make sure players are disconnecting
handle when clients do disconnect and
when they do connect of course when a
client connects and there's like my
client connection to the server the
server has a broadcast of all the other
clients you know hey this new person is
connected and there's all this stuff to
do of course and we have to maintain
some kind of data structure on the
server which contains all of our clients
right and all their information so that
we know what to send to what and anyway
it's all over the place that's what well
that's what we're going to do next time
if you want to support the series you
can pledge on patreon.com 4/2 Cherno if
you pledge five dollars or more per
month
of course you get access to this
repository which contains all of the
individual episodes committed of course
and that way you get access to all of
the source code for the entire series
including Susan one and of course it
just supports a series and make sure
that I can actually keep putting out
these videos so anyway thanks for
watching guys hit the like button if you
enjoyed the video and I'll see you next
time goodbye
you